we are here to destroy are you hello  visitors from another planet there's no  need to fight anymore  see friends they took Lucy and the  others hang on to you frogs planet  you mind if I save your life not at all  hey Rex danger vest this is my [ __ ]  dinosaur you doing space aliens  kidnapped my friends I'm going to get  them back  let it is by an alien queen I'm a queen  whatever would not be the talking horse  I could change my for but this makes you  uncomfortable hey guys go back  don't worry was much more palatable come  with me on this adventure to save my  friends teach me to be tough  let's go find your friends different did  you draw double dots on your face kill  on the way out you gonna bruise up  you almost forgot me guys oh did we I'm  literally a lantern how did you miss me  a lifetime has passed since the horrific  events of Taco Tuesday two copies please  one black one with just a touch of cream  in 25 sugars I wake up in the  you